lovely to talk to you you of course made
a documentary about Windows 25 years ago
the anniversary has provided you with an
opportunity to to revisit that what is
different between that first documentary
and the one you've made this time
good morning Jane good to talk to you
and um thanks for reminding me 25 years
ago I even had hair then I think
um
then I think that the central point was
we were writing in the book and which
was essential collection of interviews
with the men and women who had come on
that boat and still survived
um and some of their descendants
and um the when we were writing that we
were writing the origins story for what
was then black Britain and black Britain
basically meant people like me with two
black Caribbean parents
um and the reason we were Keen to write
stories because up until that point
what people knew about us was what they
generally speaking saw in the media
which was either black people rioting or
black people dancing at carnival and we
wanted to say there was much more to us
than that and if you look at these
people you've just seen pictures of
um the king meeting a man called Alfred
Gardner who's 97 years old and was
amongst these people uh when who landed
and these guys were they'd fought in the
War men in the media RAF and they were
adventurous they were talented they were
ambitious young people
um we wanted to tell that story now
what's different now is that that group
of people to which I belong are really a
minority within the minority
um there are children
um nearly a million of them who uh have
a Caribbean parent but also have a white
British parent and then even a bigger
group those who have come by what I call
the direct route from Africa about a
million and a half who um are people who
have arrived in the last 20 20 years or
so from East and West Africa and that's
changed the tone and the nature and I
think the sentiment of black Britain
quite dramatically and that's really
what we've added to the book a
description of those changes
about this is the sense of belonging and
identity has changed over the 25 years
well I I would say actually what's what
it's done is that it has
made being black and British ordinary
um I think when we wrote this book it
was the original book it was still
slightly the sense that
um we were foreigners and it's a bit of
a surprise that we were still here
whereas today
um you know you can't imagine
Britain without some of the people that
uh that he said that of uh that group
and we're talking about
um you know
supporting stars like real Ferdinand or
entertainers like Leon Lewis
um you can't imagine Britain without
those people or even actually going back
further my my great friend Trevor
McDonald can you imagine the news
without Trevor no not possible so I
think what's what we're really seeing
now when we think about British identity
is that both the people who came in
their descendants
can't imagine being anywhere else and
nor can anybody else and one of the
things that's interesting that we've
discovered talking to people in the
documentary is that
for most of us when we go to our parents
or grandparents home we're greeted
warmly and embraced but people think of
us as foreigners you know in the guy
that we in the Caribbean we say he comes
from foreign
um so in a sense we are now not just for
ourselves feeling British but our
cousins only think of us as English
people now okay uh Trevor we're gonna
have to leave it there